here's how I would respond to a Catholic
who had Ed John 6 okay let's go to John
59-62 John 6
59-62 so let me tell you how to convince
a Protestant of the Eucharist being the
physical body blood of Christ what
convinced me let's read now these things
said he in the synagogue as he taught in
capernum many therefore of his disciples
when they had heard this said this is a
hard saying who can hear it see even
disciples understood him literally Jesus
didn't correct
them when Jesus knew in himself that his
disciples murmured at it he said unto
them do this offend you what and if you
shall see the son of man Ascend up where
he was
before now here is the passage that I
would use to show'll see Jesus wasn't
speaking literally let's skip it let's
read
64-66
64-66 let's skip 63
64-66 but there are some of you that
believe not for Jesus knew from the
beginning who they were that believe not
and who it should betray him now watch
and he said therefore said I unto you
that no man can come unto me except it
were given unto him of my father from
that time many of his disciples went
back and walked no more with him see
that's it they walked away abandoned
Jesus turned their backs on Jesus never
to follow him because they were
scandalized at the notion of eating his
flesh drinking his blood literally and
physically see we got you Protestant who
denies that the Eucharist is the
physical body blood of
Christ then I said aha you forget
something John
663 watch here this is the
objection John 663 watch here guys this
is what someone like m say is in me
would bring up John
663 it is the spirit that quickeneth
gives life the flesh profiteth nothing
the words I speak unto you they are
spirit and they are life ah we got you
Catholic Jesus just explained it to the
disciples hey I'm not talking literally
here the way you eat my flesh and drink
my blood is when you hear the words that
I speak to you in Union with the Holy
Spirit and you
take in those words chew on those words
meditate on those words that's how you
eat my flesh and drink my blood Come to
Me by faith and believe my words and
chew on my words that's how you eat me
because Jesus would often explain to his
disciples the real meaning of his
Parables whereas to The Outsiders he
wouldn't because they had reached a
point of reprobation of rebellion God
was done with him because he was fed up
with their stiff neck hard-hearted
rejection of his word that's it we got
you
okay now the Catholic will insist that's
not what John 663 means the Protestant
will insist yes it does and then the
very educated Protestant will do
something to try to trip you up they
will quote St
Augustines interpretation of John 6
which I cite in that article where
Augustine says says do not get ready
your mouth don't get your mouth ready
because Jesus is not talking about
eating him with the mouth but receiving
him by faith so even Augustine
interpreted John 6
figuratively you
see so then how did I change what what
made me
change why did I change my
position can I tell you why I changed my
position
so you could have argued with me back
and forth and I would never accept I'd
say
contextually you have no case and he
said well you're twisting it said no
you're twisting
it okay you want to know why I
changed let me tell you get ready now
are you ready very simple are you
ready this is how you're going to get a
Protestant who doesn't believe the
Eucharist is the physical body blood of
Christ and not all Protestants many
Protestants already believe that right
they may not believe in
transubstantiation they may believe
consubstantiation like Mar Luther from
what I was told Lutheran episcopalians
will say yeah it is the Flesh and the
blood of Christ you don't need to
convince them high anglicans right okay
but here's
how you Hammer to the Protestant the
passages where Jesus our lord swore to
be building his church where he swore to
be with his Church to the end of the age
where he swore the Holy Spirit would
guide the church into all truth and save
it from damnable heresy and error and
how the apostles appointed men filled
with the spirit as they were to not only
teach the truth but model it and then
pass it on to others and then you
confront them with the early
church because the belief in the
Eucharist is a widespread teaching in
fact what's ironic is even the churches
in Schism that are not incomplete Union
Coptic Church of the East Catholic and
its various Stripes like Eastern you
know Byzantine Orthodox they all
agree the bread and the
cup are the physical body and blood of
Christ so then you confront them how do
you explain the widespread Universal
acceptance that the bread and the cup
when the priest prays by the grace of
Holy Spirit becomes is actually the
Flesh and the blood of Christ and you
find support for this as early as the
did the daki the
D that's what troubled
me it wasn't ex Jesus of John
6 you would never convince me in John 6
never and I know a lot of Protestants
will never be convinced you need to
confront them with the early church you
have to
but then explain why well they're not
infallible no that's not my
argument what I'm telling you is the
widespread body of
Believers all over the world without
having
internet
YouTube
television email
ups but what you'll find is the
widespread Universal belief this is the
physical body blood of Christ and if the
holy spirit is going to guide the church
and save it from damnable heresy so that
the church won't be separed from Christ
that means the Holy Spirit allowed the
Christians universally to believe this
why if it's damnable
heresy the fact that he allowed them to
believe it means it is approved by God
that's what messed me
up that's what troubled me do you know
that
and the D says that the Eucharist
fulfills the prophecy of Malachi
111 Malachi 111 and Brett's quoting the
dedicate because Malachi 111 God says
they will offer me a pure Sacrifice from
the rising of the sun to its setting
from the East and West and the diday and
all the other Christian writers
mentioned the Eucharist as f fulfilling
Malachi 111 where God says that the
Gentiles will offer to me a pure
Sacrifice from the rising of the Sun the
East to its setting in the west and the
church father said that's the Eucharist
which is celebrated East and
West that's what convinced
me you get it
now now let me explain John
663 in a manner consist with the
widespread belief that the Flesh of the
Lord Jesus the blood of the the Lord
Jesus is given to us communicated to us
through the bread and the wine at
Eucharist let me explain it are you
ready that's
consistent let's go to John 663 let me
now tell you how to interpret this it is
the spirit that quickeneth makes salive
the flesh profiteth nothing the words
that I speak unto you they are spirit
and they are life now would this
necessarily
conflict with the Eucharist being the
Flesh and the blood of Christ no think
don't you believe it has to be the Holy
Spirit who makes the bread the living
flesh and makes the wine the living
blood of Jesus so yes it is the spirit
that makes alive it is the spirit that
makes the bread the Flesh of our Lord
and the blood of Our Lord because apart
from the spirit right
there is no life it's the spirit that
makes
alive yes mere flesh can't profit you
but the flesh of Jesus and the blood of
Jesus which was conceived by the spirit
in the womb of Mary that profits you
when the spirit comes and makes the
bread and the wine the flesh and blood
of
Jesus now it makes sense doesn't
it right because even the Flesh of Jesus
even the blood of Jesus was conceived
produced and created by the Holy Spirit
from the Blessed womb of his virgin
mother
right so even that was the holy spirit's
work and unless the Holy Spirit takes
the bread and the wine and makes it the
flesh and blood of Christ all it is is
Bread and Wine there's no
conflict there's no
conflict but why do I now see it that
way because now after asking the holy
spirit to guide me into truth correct
all my false interpretations man-made
Traditions give me the grace to be
humble enough to correct myself and
accept that which is true and faithful
from him now I've yielded to this fact
now I see the passage in a manner that's
consistent with this revealed truth of
the Holy Spirit as opposed on trying to
use this passage to refute Catholics
no none of that's going to work channel
for a Protestant none of that's going to
work when you quote the Lord saying this
bread is my body and this cup is my
blood can I tell you the typical
Protestant response who doesn't believe
that the bread in the wine become the
flesh and blood of Christ can I tell you
what their response would
be can I tell
you if you quote the Lord saying this
bread is my body broken for you this cup
is my blood shed for you you know what
they're going to tell you they'll say
well number one he can't be speaking
literally do you know why because he was
alive in the flesh and his blood was in
his veins because he hadn't been
killed so he can't be speaking
literally right he hadn't been killed
he's right there alive in the flesh the
blood is in his veins so he can't be
speaking literally number two they'll
tell you we know that that night our
Lord our Lord used figurative imagery
because it's that very night where Jesus
says in John 15 I am the True Vine and
you are the branches that's no more
literal than Jesus saying the bread is
my body and the cup is my blood you see
the
problem so now we who do believe and I
do believe by the parly spirit and I
pray I believe with perfect Faith the
bread and the wine become and are the
flesh and blood of Christ how do I
respond to
that see to you it's dumb virtual but
for someone else yeah how can that be
the flesh and blood of Christ he wasn't
killed can I explain to you how what the
answer
is can I explain to you how it could be
the Flesh and the blood of Christ even
though it hadn't been killed
can I the same way the Lord is able to
make present his physical body now after
his death and resurrection that same
Lord could make present his physical
body in the Bread and Wine even before
he was crucified and
killed why can't he do
that why can't Jesus communicate his
physical body that very night before he
dies when we believe he continues to
communicate his physical body long after
his resurrection so why couldn't he do
it beforehand he can do it now that he's
risen but he can't do it before he died
why if he can do one why can't he do the
other you see the problem
now you see you see when you don't want
to be anti-catholic and just let
scripture speak and yield to whatever
the Holy Spirit wants you to accept all
of these objections vanish and dissipate
right vanish and
dissipate
right Jesus can do anything and
everything that's consistent with his
nature obviously so if the Lord can
communicate his physical body and the
bread and the wine by The Bread and Wine
becoming his flesh and blood after his
resurrection then he can do the same
thing before his
death right
uh mad says it's like asking me your
stupid question if God can simply
forgive what's the need for Jesus to die
so you're acting like a Muslim and I'm
going to send you to Mecca to kiss the
black stone God does what he wants to do
he didn't even need to become man to die
he chose therefore that same God who
chose to become a man to die for you is
the same God who chose to make the bread
and his wine the wine his flesh and
blood in order to communicate his life
to us until he takes us into Glory